des places prisé et un public qui répond
présent la troisième édition du tournoi
et sport tas de nouveau fait le plein ce
week-end plus de 200 joueurs se sont
affrontés durant tout un après-midi
amateurs comme professionnels ou des
lancers que gpj dof du mad as fait
j'avais mon niveau et ça m'a fait
plaisir le but était de jouer se fait
plaisir
j'en sens très content parce que je
pensais pas passer le premier tour final
je vais passer assez facilement j'ai
sorti premier de la poule
du coup fier de moi quand même le jeu
est très très jeune on a besoin d'eux
entre guillemets agrandir la communauté
est donc là ça me permet de rencontrer
de nouvelles personnes et puis de jouer
avec des joueurs que j'affectionne après
deux saisons tourner autour de eur stone
tournoi s'est ouvert à deux nouveaux
jeux du football avec fifa 20 et league
of legends le numéro un du monde de
l'histoire qui vient de fêter ses 10 ans
ça chauffe
les autres
l'idée c'était que les jeux c'est un peu
comme des disciplines sportives on a
beau être sportif si on joue pas au
rugby on va pas forcément suivent le
rugby donc à l'idée c'était d'avoir plus
de diversité plus de personnes qui
étaient intéressés mais pas forcément
sur un seul jeu donc là ça a permis
d'avoir des communautés trois joueurs on
peut imaginer qu'ils ont rappelé de cap
et les vainqueurs se sont partagé près
de 4000 euros de dotation les équipes
pensent déjà à une quatrième édition